So when you were partying,
what was your thing?
Does doing cocaine by myself at the house.
Really?
Cocaine.
Yeah.
It was all cocaine.
Dude in cocaine.
Oh go back to their vest or a man.
So here's what happened.
So I would get fucked up and put these
vests on and put on sunglasses and not
let them know like Buffalo Bill Shit,
but at least party and by myself,
you know,
and I was making like a nice smoothie
and I'm fucking coked up on partying,
you know,
live in home.
The hawkers to vests on maybe.
Right.
And I thought,
I thought I heard something outside.
Right.
Which is kind of weird to even think
of when you have a blender going,
right?
So I leave out of my apartment
to go in the hallway,
lock myself out with the blender,
going to be 30 in the morning,
coked up out of my brain and I have to
go to my landlord dude who lives right
down the hall and tell him like,
hey man,
I got logged out.
I'm like,
oh my God,
he must have hated you.
Oh,
the blender shorts out and smoke happens.
The fire alarm starts
going off in the building,
right as I'm ad is door
knocking right now.
He's pissed and he's like,
what's going on?
And I didn't know what to say.
I told him that I was throwing
a late Christmas party.
Dude,
it was fucking into January.
I will with you at the time,
Huh?
Oh,
this is two and a half years ago was 35
so he comes back to my apartment,
right?
He's,
he unlocks the door.
There's nobody in there.
Oh my God.
I'm like,
man.
But that's it.
It was fun.
How long did you live there for?
I still live there.
Whoa.
We've passion.
You know,
like I've caught him doing some things.
I think we're all even.